alors revenons à faire un anti portrait
chinois le portrait chinois c'est si tu
étais une fleur jeu sera un mieux aux
autistes lentilles portrait chinois
c'est des choses qui sont plus noirs en
général
attention vous êtes prêts
bien si vous étiez un défaut c'est un
défaut je serai ce serait un bon jour
une injure pas ce soir chéri j'ai la
migraine maladie mais j'aurai la
bougeotte une perversion ce serait de me
le marquer avec une poupée gonflable un
vis à vis
j'ai pas se serait appelée ta femme par
exemple une trahison décès en silicone
ouais plus une arme une arme des talons
aiguilles
1 une cicatrice une marque de rouge à
lèvres sur le but de ma de ma cravate un
poison
ce sera une une compilation de julio
iglesias un volet fab un [ __ ] un
[ __ ] un [ __ ] ce serait un alcoolique
au volant oui parce que ce que ce que
vous dites en fait c'est que vous en
voulez pas au monde entier en 9 71 tout
ça je suis planté tout ça
ce qui est terrible c'est les gens qui
seront plantés au terrible mecs qui
passent dans la rue lafitte fait rien
type qui sait me dont il peut carrément
identifier celui qui a pris ça dur l'air
vous étiez un dictateur ce serait ce
serait le litani tu as tout manon si
vous étiez une torture ce serait je sais
pas moi condé complète ne way une
humiliation une humiliation camping mon
fauteuil roulant ce serait bien dans la
merde
un accident au ce serait de tomber
amoureux
voilà oui le sable est malade cardiaque
chez robert laffont